many of us regularly recycle items like
plastic milk bottles and glass bottles
from our kitchens but it's also easy to
recycle lots of items from other places
in and around your home let's start in
the bathroom you can recycle lots of
things from here shampoo bleach and
bathroom cleaner bottles toilet roll
tubes and toothpaste boxes in the living
room you can also recycle old newspapers
cans and envelopes it's good to know
that recycling one drinks can could save
enough energy to power a TV for four
hours and from the bedroom magazines as
well as cardboard tissue boxes and
aerosols now back to the kitchen you can
also recycle breakfast cereal dishwasher
and kitchen wrap boxes and tubes washing
up liquid and pop bottles and all your
tins and cans everything you recycle
brings real benefits it comes back again
and again as new stuff saving resources
and the environment for example plastic
bottles can be recycled into footage
shirts fleeces and new plastic bottles
to find out what you can recycle in your
area visit recycle now calm